so you get the call and they say taylor
swift wants you to come do this this
project with her what happens in that
moment
uh i was giddy
um yeah i couldn't believe uh
it's really funny it was like i think i
had woken up to like a text from my
manager and it was like
taylor swift wants to talk to you about
something and i was like that's
an unreal to i was like so foggy too and
like i had my night guard and i was like
what are you talking about um
uh and then yeah and then like we texted
and then jumped on the phone and then um
it's funny my my friend sarah was like
the biggest fifty of all time like
guests knew exactly like what it was for
she's like i wonder if it's gonna be for
this uh and
yeah and then we talked shot on the
phone um
and then she asked me like what i
thought and if i and if i wanted time to
think and i was like oh it's a yes what
do you mean even before sarah would kill
me if i yeah what are you talking about
it's 100 i'm in all right i love that
and now you're in the swifty's universe
you see what happens yeah yeah like this
is madness right yeah i watched the film
the 13-minute short film yes you and
sadie the chemistry the like what was
that like working with her and then also
working with taylor as a director and
she wrote it and she produced and she's
in it yeah it was i mean so much credit
to taylor uh because yeah i mean it's
not easy to i guess achieve something
like that it's such a you know nuanced
like
relationship dynamics is it's really
hard to execute you know um and and i
think it's really challenging um and the
stage that she set though and just even
in her lyrics and and in her
her vision for the film and the
lookbooks and this the situations that
she put us in you know made it really
easy i think because they were such
authentic insightful
like situations you know so
um
yeah it was just about i mean being set
up for success you know there was never
a moment where i i felt like it was
wasn't easy because and i think that's
that's a lot to do with her and lastly
can you get all too well out of your
head now
it's so funny yeah i was working on
something else i had to fly to do this
and so when i went back to set and i was
just like humming it all week it was so
funny
you